over the past few decades advances in
technology have improved our lives in
both big and small ways from phones we
unlock with our faces to devices
counting our steps to filters that turn
us into talking cats oh i've always
wanted to try this
what's the matter batman
don't like a kitty with claws
technology is supposed to make our lives
more convenient and more equitable
because unlike people computers and
algorithms can't be racist but
what if they totally are let me explain
in a segment called how did we get here
[Music]
now technology exists to make our lives
better but sometimes things that are
there to make life easier actually make
some people's lives a lot harder the
problems can show up in tiny annoying
ways like this story about automatic
soap dispensers that don't recognize
black hands that's right think of
automatic soap dispensers like the tv
show friends they're clean they're
everywhere and they're totally unaware
that black people exist
but here's the thing when it comes to
technology and black people it's not
just our hands that are getting done
dirty first let's talk about something
called artificial intelligence or ai
that's basically when computers are
programmed to do things that usually
take human brains it's how you get
personalized shopping recommendations on
instagram or why google maps can tell
you how to avoid traffic or why anyone
who named their daughter alexa is going
to be apologizing for the rest of their
life
alexa i'm sorry alexa shut up not you
alexa no no alexa i'm gonna kill you not
you alexa you alexa die live alexa
now
we like to think that computers are
neutral but the fact is ai is programmed
by people and people are biased bias is
part of the human condition like love or
death or having to whisper ready tidy
lefty loosey every time you open a jar
but
that bias has real world consequences
take google you know the place where you
search your ex-boyfriend's name six
times a day even though you know you can
do better because that idiot only owns
one tail
in 2015 a black software developer named
jackie alcine realized that when google
photos used ai to categorize his
pictures they sorted images of him and
his black friend into a folder titled
gorillaz
which is insanely racist in fact it's so
racist i give it six months before that
algorithm gets its own fox news show
google's
racist ai isn't just a one-time thing in
one experiment it labeled a thermometer
held by a white hand as an electronic
device and the same object held by a
dark skin hand as a gun
which is unacceptable because in this
country the only people allowed to
confuse random objects for guns are the
police officers
but algorithms that label pictures are
just the tip of an extremely racist
iceberg there's also an arbitrary face
scanning algorithm that claims it can
use ai to find out who is best for a job
by scanning their face
there's an algorithm that claims to
predict which criminals will reoffend
that has been known to falsely flag
black defendants as future criminals at
almost twice the rate as white
defendants now there's a medical
algorithm that favors white patients
over sick or black ones which is
unforgivable in a system that already
treats black people like an afterthought
unfortunately in america getting
appropriate health care is a lot like
playing chess when you're white you
always get to go first that's why my
strategy and either one is to just yell
king me and see if i get anything extra
but as bad as all those other examples
are perhaps the most alarming use of ai
involves facial recognition technology
recently a black computer scientist
named joy blamwini found out that she
couldn't get the robots she worked with
to detect her face she couldn't figure
out why until halloween when she wore a
white mask that's when the robots
immediately recognized her as a person
let me repeat that a black woman
literally wasn't recognized as a human
being unless she wore a white mask a
metaphor so on the nose it's basically a
nostril
it's less a metaphor and more a solid
ending for a jordan peel movie
and by the way the only person who
should have to wear a white mask to get
attention is this guy
we get it phantom you love your love
language is chandeliers and attempted
murder
but
joys isn't the worst facial recognition
story because if there's anything
scarier than having algorithms ignore
you it's having them do exactly the
opposite just last year a man named
robert williams was arrested for
stealing five watches because facial
rage facial recognition technology
decided his id matched a photo of the
thief there's just one teensy thing
though it was not him in the photo in
fact he had an alibi and even the
detectives admitted the picture wasn't
him but that didn't stop him from having
to pay bond find an attorney and go to
court and the thing is mr williams isn't
alone according to a federal study on
facial recognition asian and
african-american people were up to 100
times more likely to be misidentified
than white people which is insane at
this point you can't even call it facial
recognition anymore it's just
a ridiculously expensive machine that
tells you if someone has a face
so the real question here is what's
causing these racist algorithms and how
do we fix it well let me say it again
computers are programmed by people and
people are biased not just white people
everyone i know i am for example
i think that any couple that rides a
tandem bicycle is definitely plotting
each other's murder
that's a bias i have and i'm not afraid
to admit it but in the case of an ai
in but in the case of ai everyday biases
have
life-changing consequences basically the
[ __ ] we put into our computers is
the [ __ ] that comes out like they
used to say in church garbage in garbage
out can the church say amen
ha ha you're a church so
that means we need diverse faces
training the ai and diverse brains
building it and if women and people of
color aren't included in the ai process
the technology will continue to exclude
us or even worse target us and we can't
let that happen because unless you're a
ghost haunting an opera house this
should never have to be part of your
work uniform this has been how do we get
here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you